-Olivier Rey,
philosophe
et mathématicien.
Vous interrogez inlassablement
les travers de la modernité.
Eclairant, de la part
d'un scientifique.
Votre critique de l'abstraction,
pour le dire vite,
qu'on retrouve dans la statistique,
dans un langage d'expert,
et dans la rationalisation
de la société,
permet d'apporter
un diagnostic,
de la crise, à la fois,
climatique et civilisationnelle,
que nous traversons.
Au fond, et pour reprendre
votre expression,
la crise ne relève-t-elle pas
d'une question de taille ?
-Elle relève de beaucoup de choses,
entre autres,
d'une question de taille.
La chose
que je voudrais dire,
c'est que si je suis un critique
de la modernité,
ça n'est pas
en tant que la modernité
serait une époque
forcément pire que les autres,
mais c'est la mienne.
La modernité,
en tant que telle,
a sa légitimité,
et a ses qualités.
Mais elle a aussi ses défauts.
C'est ses défauts auxquels
il ne faut pas être aveugle,
pour éviter qu'ils ne nous
conduisent à la catastrophe.
Depuis l'origine,
l'humanité est guetté
par la catastrophe,
et elle y échappe, précisément,
parce que les hommes,
depuis qu'il y a des hommes
sur la Terre n'ont cessé
de s'avertir des dangers
qu'ils couraient.
-La critique de la modernité
est un préalable
à la catastrophe
que charrierait
aussi la modernité.
Vous critiquez la modernité
car vous en faites
partie, mais bon,
néanmoins,
elle a des défauts
qui lui sont consubstantiels.
-Elle a des défauts
comme toutes les époques
ont eu des défauts...
La particularité
de notre époque,
c'est qu'avec, d'une part,
la multiplication
des hommes sur la Terre,
et l'explosion
des moyens technologiques,
et ce qu'on appelle
la mondialisation
ou la globalisation,
les catastrophes
qui, auparavant,
étaient limitées,
risquent de devenir globales.
Une des choses
qui nous menacent
particulièrement aujourd'hui,
c'est une forme de cécité
aux enjeux essentiels
qui se jouent sur le plan
quantitatif, parce qu'en fait,
le quantitatif,
lorsqu'on passe certains seuils,
ça devient du qualitatif.
J'ai été particulièrement rendu
attentif à ces questions
par mon passé
de mathématicien,
car je m'occupais
d'équations
aux dérivées partielles
non-linéaires.
Que veut dire "non-linéaire" ?
Quand les variables varient
proportionnellement
les unes par rapport aux autres,
la seule différence entre
le petit et le grand,
c'est juste la taille.
Quand on a des liens
non-linéaires,
ce qu'il se passe,
c'est qu'à certains moments,
on a des effets de seuil,
qui peuvent nous faire
basculer d'un certain régime,
dans un autre régime
complètement différent.
En sciences physiques,
on connaît bien ça.
Exemple :
les transitions de phases.
Si on prend de l'eau
et qu'on la chauffe,
sous une pression atmosphérique
normale, on arrive à 100 degrés
et l'eau se transforme en vapeur.
On a un très bel exemple où on a
une transformation quantitative,
l'augmentation
de la température,
qui produit un effet
qualitatif dramatique.
Entre l'eau liquide
et la vapeur,
le moins qu'on puisse dire,
c'est que la différence
est énorme.
Ca se rencontre
partout en sciences physiques.
Ca se retrouve en biologie
et évidemment, à l'intérieur
des sociétés humaines.
Attention à ne pas forcer
les analogies
entre ce qui se passe
en physique, en biologie,
et dans le monde humain.
Une phrase de Georges Canguilhem
que j'ai en tête dit :
"Pour un organisme,
l'organisation,
"c'est son fait,
pour les sociétés humaines,
"c'est leur affaire."
Voilà.
Cela n'empêche pas que
dans tous les domaines,
les questions de taille
sont absolument essentielles.
Si on n'y est pas attentif,
on va au devant de surprises
qui peuvent être
catastrophiques.
-On n'y est pas attentifs,
car ça fait partie du rêve moderne
que de ne pas avoir de limite.
Comment faire pour
revenir à la limite ?
-Il y a 2 choses.
Il y a effectivement
un mouvement moderne
qui considère la limite non pas
comme quelque chose à respecter
mais a priori comme
quelque chose à transgresser.
Je fais partie d'un organisme,
le CNRS,
qui a dans son logo, inscrit :
"Dépasser les frontières".
Là, on voit bien
l'ambition moderne.
On attribue à Hercule,
dans l'Antiquité,
le fait d'avoir écrit
sur les colonnes,
qui portent son nom,
les colonnes d'Hercule,
"Nec plus ultra".
Pas plus loin.
Et Charles Quint avait pris
comme devise de son empire,
"Plus ultra". Plus loin.
On voit le basculement
qu'il y a entre
une sagesse ancienne
qui prônait les limites
et un mouvement moderne
qui va vers leur dépassement.
Attention
de ne pas idéaliser
les anciens.
Si les anciens s'avertissaient
des dangers qu'il y avait
à transgresser
certaines limites,
c'est qu'ils avaient tendance
à les franchir.
Mais au moins
s'avertissaient-ils
des dangers.
C'est vrai qu'avec
la modernité,
on a l'idée que toute limite
est promise à être dépassée.
Mais d'autre part,
l'inconscience qu'il y a
autour du fait qu'il y a
des effets de seuil...
Ce qui fait
que ce qu'on imaginait
obtenir en franchissant
certaines limites
ne correspond pas du tout,
parce que, précisément,
les bouleversements qualitatifs
apparaissent.
Il y a une cécité
particulière
de la modernité
à ces question de taille.
Une des raisons
que je pourrais
voir à ce fait,
c'est la grande séparation
qui s'est opérée
dans l'université moderne, disons.
Avec la philosophe qui a été
versée du côté des Lettres
et les mathématiques qui ont été
versés du côté des sciences.
Ce qui fait
que la philosophie a abandonné
le domaine du quantitatif,
aux sciences
et aux mathématiques.
Le philosophe a eu tendance
à se cantonner
à un domaine conceptuel,
où il ignore tout
du quantitatif.
Ce qui est très
problématique
car les concepts eux-mêmes
ont un domaine de validité
qui doit prendre en compte
un certain horizon quantitatif.
Si on prend la démocratie,
aujourd'hui, classiquement,
on va apprendre à des élèves
que la démocratie naît à Athènes
au 5e siècle avant Jésus-Christ,
avec des imperfections.
On fait comme s'il y avait
naissance de la démocratie
qui pouvait
se conserver inchangée
entre une cité
où il y avait quelques dizaines
de milliers de citoyens,
et je ne sais pas, moi,
l'Inde moderne,
où il va y avoir bientôt
1,5 milliard d'habitants
et pratiquement 1 milliard
de gens inscrits
sur les listes électorales.
Pour moi,
c'est un peu...
Ranger aussi bien l'Athènes
du 5e siècle avant Jésus-Christ,
que les Etats-Unis,
ou que l'Inde moderne,
sous la même rubrique
de démocratie,
c'est comme si
on rangeait dans la même catégorie
les vaches et les tables,
au prétexte que les deux
ont quatre pieds.
C'est sûr que dans les 2 cas,
il y a des procédures de vote,
mais le fonctionnement général
n'a rien à voir.
Dans les deux cas,
parler de démocratie,
employer le même mot,
c'est se condamner
à un aveuglement total
aux effets de seuil
qui interviennent
lorsqu'une population
dépasse certains seuils.
-Entre les deux, il y a quand même
eu des révolutions épistémologiques,
et notamment la transformation
du cosmos en univers, on va dire.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai l'impression
qu'on prône un retour au cosmos.
Euh... Alors.
Alors, un mot de vocabulaire.
Pourquoi la terminologie "cosmos"
plutôt qu'"univers" ?
-Le mot "cosmos", en grec ancien,
ça signifiait, au départ,
un ensemble harmonieux,
bien ordonné.
Euh... C'est ce sens-là
qu'on a chez Homère...
Quand Agamemnon range son armée
bien en ordre de bataille,
pour attaquer Troie,
son armée est cosmique.
Car elle est bien rangée.
On a encore un signe
en français moderne,
dans le mot "cosmétique",
qui vient de "kosmêtikos".
C'est ce qui est fait,
dans la mesure du possible,
dans mon cas, c'est difficile,
nos traits plus harmonieux.
Voilà.
Quand les premiers
philosophes grecs,
vers le 6e siècle
avant Jésus-Christ,
ont cherché un mot pour désigner
l'ensemble de ce qui est,
ça n'existait pas.
Ils ont été pêché ce mot.
Ca voulait dire
que d'emblée,
ils considéraient
que l'ensemble de ce qui est,
est un ensemble harmonieux
et bien ordonné.
A ce moment,
la mission
d'un être humain,
à l'intérieur du cosmos,
c'est de s'insérer
comme il convient,
dans cet ordre
qui est harmonieux.
Ce qui va se passer
à l'époque moderne,
le grand évènement,
c'est l'avènement
du système de Copernic.
C'est comme ça
qu'on voit à quel point
l'émoi était grand
autour de l'avènement
du système de Copernic.
C'est vraiment un changement
d'univers mental énorme,
parce que dans un cosmos,
chaque chose était à la place
qui lui revenait
en fonction de sa nature,
et donc si la Terre
était au centre...
Il faut voir
que le centre,
c'était pas le meilleur lieu
du cosmos.
C'était au contraire
le pire.
Au fur et à mesure qu'on montait
dans les sphères célestes,
on allait vers toujours mieux,
et c'est pour ça
que quand on était
"au septième ciel",
qui est un fossile,
dans notre langue,
de cette ancienne conception,
on était dans un état
extrêmement enviable.
On avait une rivalité
entre monde terrestre et céleste.
Si on prend au sérieux
le système de Copernic,
l'opposition entre ces mondes
n'a plus aucun sens,
puisque la Terre
est un astre
pareil aux autres,
mais à partir du moment
où on perd cette distinction,
toutes les distinctions cosmiques
sont dévalorisées.
A ce moment-là,
on se retrouve
dans ce que Koyré appelle
"l'univers infini".
Ca va avoir
des effets considérables,
puisque dans un cosmos,
le monde est considéré
comme bien ordonné.
Il y a une sorte
d'articulation
entre les questions de fait
et ce que les modernes appelleront
les "questions de valeur",
alors que justement,
avec la modernité,
on va avoir une séparation
entre les questions de fait,
dont va s'occuper la science,
et de l'autre côté la morale,
les valeurs,
qui est vraiment déracinée
de tout ancrage
dans les choses.
-Donc, divorce,
entre les valeurs et les faits.
On entre dans le champ moderne,
le paradigme moderne,
et vous dites que finalement,
on est toujours
dans ce paradigme moderne,
et c'est l'une des raisons
qui font que notre rapport au monde
s'est transformé.
Vous prenez en exemple
l'usage des mots.
Par exemple, le mot "eau",
qui raconte un peu l'évolution
de notre rapport au monde.
-Dans l'ancienne pensée cosmique,
l'eau était l'un des éléments
fondamentaux avec la terre,
l'air et le feu.
Si on prend les premiers
dictionnaires français
apparaissant au 17e siècle,
en particulier
le dictionnaire de Furetière,
l'eau est définie
comme un des quatre éléments.
Et puis,
plutôt qu'une définition
de l'eau,
on a une énumération des endroits
où on rencontre l'eau :
l'eau de mer, l'eau de rivière,
l'eau du puits...
Et puis, si on prend
n'importe quel dictionnaire actuel,
en gros, la définition,
c'est :
"Eau, liquide incolore,
"inodore,
sans saveur à l'état pur,
"formé par combinaison d'oxygène
et d'hydrogène,
"de formule chimique H2O."
Et là, en fait,
quand vous prenez
la définition de l'eau au 17e
et la définition de l'eau
au 21e siècle,
sur cet élément,
pourtant si simple,
on mesure l'ampleur
de la transformation,
avec ses avantages,
et ses inconvénients.
Il est clair
que les sciences mathématiques
de la nature,
dont la chimie fait partie,
qui aboutissent à cette définition
de l'eau comme H2O,
ont permis aussi une maîtrise
technologique extraordinaire,
ce qui fait que l'eau,
c'est d'abord pour nous,
dans nos pays,
ce qui coule au robinet.
Ma mère,
quand elle était institutrice...
Une année,
elle devait corriger
ce qui restait
du certificat d'études.
Il y avait une question posée
aux candidats qui était :
"Quels sont les trois états
de l'eau ?"
L'un des candidats
avait répondu :
"L'eau du robinet, l'eau des WC,
l'eau de piscine."
Il rit.
On attendait plutôt l'eau liquide,
la glace et la vapeur d'eau,
mais enfin bon.
Ce qui était très touchant,
finalement, dans cette réponse,
c'était que le candidat
en question
avait une définition qui était
très semblable à celle de Furetière.
-Oui.
-Il disait :
"L'eau de rivière, l'eau de mer,
"l'eau de la source..."
-L'eau sensible, quoi.
-Sauf que lui,
là où il rencontrait l'eau,
c'était d'abord
au robinet, aux WC
et à la piscine.
Ce qu'il y a,
c'est que si aujourd'hui,
les habitants des grandes métropoles
rencontrent l'eau de cette manière,
c'est parce qu'il y a
toute une infrastructure
technologique
qui nous amène l'eau,
qui la fait couler à volonté,
en plus, une eau traitée,
de telle sorte qu'on ne risque pas
de s'empoisonner avec.
Il ne faut absolument pas nier
l'immense confort
que cela nous apporte.
-Qu'est-ce qu'on perd ?
-Ce que l'on perd aussi,
c'est un certain rapport direct
aux éléments,
qui appauvrit grandement
notre humanité.
On a tendance aujourd'hui
à réduire le monde
aux services
qu'il peut nous rendre,
mais avant
de nous rendre des services,
la nature est d'abord
un vis-à-vis
qui nous aide aussi
à nous comprendre nous-mêmes.
J'ai été très marqué
par les écrits
de Bachelard, d'autant
que je fais partie de l'institut
d'histoire et de philosophie
des sciences et des techniques,
dont Bachelard a été directeur
pendant 15 ans de 1940 à 1955.
Ce qui est intéressant
chez Bachelard, c'est que d'un côté,
il s'est passionné
pour les sciences de son temps,
mais en même temps, il y a
une seconde partie dans son oeuvre
où il va se consacrer
aux différents éléments,
écrire "La psychanalyse du feu",
"L'Air et les songes",
"La terre et les rêveries du repos",
etc.,
et un livre consacrée à l'eau,
"L'eau et les rêves".
Vous voyez qu'on peut écrire
un livre qui s'appelle
"L'eau et les rêves" mais pas
"H20 et les rêves".
H20, non, il y a aucun rêve.
Or, le rêve, ça fait
quand même partie
aussi de notre humanité.
-Il y a une chose qui a subi
ce désenchantement,
et en même temps une forme
de sacralisation,
ce qui est paradoxal,
c'est la vie.
Pourriez-vous en dire un mot ?
-La vie, il faudrait encore...
-La définir.
-C'est un mot extrêmement riche.
C'est aussi extraordinaire
de constater dans les dictionnaires
l'évolution de la manière
dont on la définie.
Si on dit, comme Littré,
que la vie,
c'est...
l'ensemble des fonctions
qui caractérisent
les êtres vivants,
la nutrition,
la digestion...
Voilà, toutes ces fonctions-là...
Dans "Les Evangiles",
Jésus-Christ dit :
"Je suis le chemin,
la vérité et la vie."
Il dit pas : "Je suis la nutrition,
la digestion, etc."
On voit bien que là,
il y a pas du tout synonyme.
C'est une des choses
qui m'avaient mis très mal à l'aise
à l'époque de l'épidémie de Covid,
où il avait été dit
qu'on mettrait tout en oeuvre
pour sauver dans vies.
Quelle est la définition
qu'on donnait au mot "vie" ?
Et dans les faits,
avec le décompte des morts
qu'on avait tous les jours,
ce qu'on voulait maintenir,
c'était des vies au sens biologique,
la fonction vitale.
Il fallait que ça continue.
Et on s'interrogeait pas tellement
sur ce qu'était une vie humaine.
C'est un mot très riche,
en français, quand on dit :
"C'est pas une vie."
Ca veut dire qu'une vie humaine
ne doit pas être menée
de cette manière-là,
alors même qu'on a toujours
la nutrition, la digestion,
toutes les fonctions vitales
qui fonctionnent.
-Et au fond,
la façon dont on a entendu
le mot "vie" lors de la pandémie,
et cette idée que la vie
doit être ce qui doit être
conservé à tout prix,
c'est un peu la même définition
que les transhumanistes ?
-Oui, ça vient même de plus loin,
parce que...
Alors là, on a une énorme
différence, aussi,
entre la pensée ancienne
et médiévale
et la pensée moderne.
Dans sa "Physique", Aristote
définit les objets de la physique.
Quels sont les objets
de la physique ?
Les animaux, les plantes
et les éléments,
terre, air, eau et feu.
Mais dans sa numération
des objets de la physique,
ça commence par le vivant.
Les animaux, les plantes.
Et c'est normal parce qu'en grec,
"phusis", qui a donné "physique",
qu'on traduit en latin
par "natura"
et en langue moderne, "nature",
la "phusis",
c'est lié au verbe "phuien",
qui veut dire "naître, croître,
ce qui se présente
"de soi-même".
C'est le vivant qui est évidemment
l'emblème de cela,
et ça veut dire que pour Aristote,
et pour les anciens, en réalité,
le monde est pensé
à partir du vivant.
En latin, "natura",
c'est lié aussi au verbe "nascor",
"naître, nature, nativité".
C'est la même racine.
Quand au 17e siècle,
Galilée dit :
"le livre de la nature
est écrit en langue mathématique",
on change de monde.
D'ailleurs, on retrouve
l'importance du système de Copernic.
Pour les anciens,
il y avait monde terrestre,
monde céleste.
Le monde céleste,
c'était le monde des régularités,
et comme il était régulier,
on pouvait l'appréhender
par les mathématiques
parce que les objets mathématiques
sont eux-mêmes immuables.
En revanche, sur la Terre,
où il y a du vivant,
ça naît, ça meurt, ça pourrit,
les mathématiques sont inadaptées.
-Il y a de la contingence.
-Voilà, et à partir
du moment où on abolit
la distinction entre terrestre
et céleste, c'est ce qui permet
à Galilée de dire :
"Puisque les mathématiques
sont vraies
"dans le monde céleste
et qu'il y a pas de différence
"entre les deux mondes,
"elles doivent être valables
partout."
Et on a remporté des succès
absolument extraordinaires,
en particulier Newton
à la fin du 17e siècle,
avec sa loi de la gravitation
universelle qui montre
que ce sont les même équations
qui régissent
la trajectoire des astres
dans le ciel
et la chute des corps sur Terre.
Extraordinaire.
Mais ce qui se passe,
c'est que malgré tout,
à un moment donné, on va rencontrer
des problèmes avec le vivant,
parce que le vivant résiste
à la mathématisation.
Qu'est-ce qui fait
que spontanément,
autour de nous, on fait
la distinction entre le non vivant
et le vivant ?
C'est qu'on repère spontanément
dans le vivant le fait que le vivant
a un principe d'animation interne,
c'est-à-dire
qu'il ne se comporte pas uniquement
en fonction des forces externes
qui s'exercent sur lui,
mais qu'il a un principe interne.
Et ce principe interne,
précisément, justement,
on peut pas l'objectiver, bon.
Il y a beaucoup de choses
objectivables dans le vivant,
mais le vivant en tant que tel...
-Il y a quelque chose
d'irréductible.
-Oui, et alors,
les biologistes vont se retrouver
dans une situation inconfortable,
parce que d'un côté,
ils étudient le vivant,
mais de l'autre, comme ils ont envie
que leur science soit moderne,
ils ont énormément de mal
à reconnaître ce qu'on appelle
la téléologie, la finalité
à l'intérieur des êtres vivants.
Il va y avoir une formation
de compromis
qui va émerger, qui est
qu'on est bien forcés de reconnaître
à l'intérieur du vivant
qu'il y a une finalité,
mais on va réduire cette finalité
à un seul principe
qui est le principe
de conservation
et de multiplication.
En fait, c'est une conception
extrêmement pauvre du vivant,
puisqu'on ne considère pas le vivant
en tant que ce qu'il a
en tant que vivant
particulier à être
mais simplement en tant qu'être
qui cherche à se conserver.
-Persévérance.
-C'est là qu'on peut faire le lien
avec le transhumanisme.
On pourrait dire que la mission
première d'une être humain,
c'est d'accomplir un destin humain.
Mais d'un autre côté, si vous dites
qu'en fait, notre seule mission,
c'est de vivre
le plus longtemps possible,
on peut imaginer
toutes les transformations possibles
pour prolonger
le processus vital.
Saint Thomas d'Aquin dit :
"Un âne ne souhaite pas
devenir cheval
"car il cesserait
d'être un âne."
L'âne, sa première mission
sur Terre,
c'est d'être un bon âne,
et il va pas...
Certes, s'il était un cheval,
il pourrait courir plus vite,
mais ne il serait plus un âne.
Mais si on réduit la vie
à sa conservation,
il n'y a plus d'objection.
C'est là
où on voit que tout se tient.
-Olivier Rey,
quel est le rôle du philosophe
dans la cité ?
Est-ce que c'est de remettre
la question du nombre
au coeur de la réflexion ?
Est-ce qu'il doit devenir roi
de la république ?
Est-ce qu'il est l'ermite
ou le conseiller du prince,
ou encore autre chose ?
-J'ai l'impression
que pendant longtemps,
la philosophie
s'est forcée de penser l'être.
Ensuite, quand le monde
s'est mis à se transformer
de manière de plus en plus rapide,
sa grande mission,
ça a été de penser le devenir.
Et aujourd'hui,
je dirais que ça va tellement vite
que ce serait essayer de penser
ce qui nous arrive.
Peter Sloterdijk dit :
"Le rôle du philosophe est d'essayer
de penser dans l'avalanche."
On est pris
dans un gigantesque processus.
Donc je dirais
que ce que j'essaie de faire,
c'est de penser ce processus,
ce qui nous arrive,
sans s'illusionner sur le fait
qu'on puisse y changer grand-chose,
parce que précisément, le processus
est devenu tellement puissant
et gigantesque...
Quand on est dans une avalanche,
la seule chose qu'on puisse faire,
c'est d'attendre que ça se calme,
parce que dans l'avalanche,
on est pris dedans.
Cela étant,
ce que je pense,
c'est que ce processus
est en train de s'effilocher,
de se déliter gravement,
qu'au cours du 21e siècle,
il va y avoir des bouleversements
très importants, et que si on reste
complètement pris dans le processus,
on ne pourra vivre
les turbulences
à l'intérieur du processus
que comme des catastrophes
alors que d'un autre côté,
c'est aussi des chances
que nous aurons, précisément,
de rouvrir des possibilités de vie
qui aujourd'hui,
sont canalisées
dans une direction.
Je dirais qu'à ce moment-là,
la philosophie,
elle retrouvera le rôle
que lui assignait Nietzsche
dans l'Antiquité :
d'inventer des possibilités de vie.
-Le philosophe
qui vous a construit ?
-Justement, j'ai prononcé
le nom de Nietzsche.
Je dirais pas
que Nietzsche m'a construit,
mais c'est vraiment par lui
que je me suis intéressé
à la philosophie,
que j'y suis entré.
Je dirais que la première
caractéristique de Nietzsche,
par rapport à d'autres philosophes,
c'est que c'est quelqu'un,
quand on est jeune,
qui vous demande
quelque chose.
Nietzsche est pas un constructeur,
il est plutôt destructeur,
mais c'est un éveilleur.
-Même si on l'a compris,
pourriez-vous formuler
la grande question philosophique
d'aujourd'hui ?
-Bon, s'il faut en choisir une,
je dirais :
redonner un sens positif
à la limite.
Vous voyez, dans un cosmos,
la limite a un sens positif
puisque comme l'ensemble
est conçu comme harmonieux,
bien ordonné,
il faut respecter
la mesure.
La modernité, c'est un
des grands enjeux
du passage du monde clos, cosmos,
à l'univers infini,
la limite devient toujours
un obstacle à franchir.
Elle est soit déniée,
soit, quand on la reconnaît,
on la reconnaît comme contrainte.
C'est ce qui se passe
dans l'écologie.
Il y a toute une écologie
qui va dire : "On ravage la Terre
donc il faut se restreindre."
Mais on se retreint parce qu'on peut
pas faire autrement.
Sinon, on détruit tout.
Mais si on pouvait continuer
comme on le fait,
il y aurait pas d'objection.
Dans l'écologie actuelle,
la véritable motivation,
c'est ça ou la mort.
Mais on pourrait dire
que la limite,
c'est d'abord
une question de vertu.
Je pense que ce serait vraiment
une tâche très importante
que d'être capable
de recevoir la limite
comme éminemment positive,
comme ce qui fait être,
ce qui donne forme,
ce qui fait échapper à l'informe,
ce qui est du ressort
de la vertu.
Alors cela étant, sur ce terrain-là,
il faut reconnaître
que la philosophie n'est peut-être
pas la meilleure... instance.
Les mythes étaient beaucoup
plus efficaces que la philosophie.
Dans l'Antiquité, cette sagesse
se véhiculait d'abord
par les mythes avant de l'être
par la philosophie.
Il y a la littérature.
Il y a le narratif, je pense,
qui est peut-être plus efficace
que le spéculatif, pour redonner
un sens positif à la limite.
-On a besoin des deux.
Merci, Olivier Rey.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA